bonjour bienvenue dans la 50e de ses
caches déjà 50 je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous aimeraient être à ma place
mais je ne la cédraie pas je reste à
côtés d'estelle
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du titre tesla et des
implications que ça peut avoir sur la
bourse en général
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce 50e épisode de
sc cash déjà 50 numéros olivier et oui
50 numéros ce que je vous disais
beaucoup vont regretter de ne pas être à
ma place mais je ne la cédraie pour rien
au monde elle est foutue c'est cette
semaine sur le spécialiste des voitures
électriques haut de gamme tesla
l'entreprise californienne porté par
elon musk a connu une fois l'ascension
boursière début février avant de
décrocher on va s'intéresser au parcours
boursier de tesla est elle déjà un géant
de l'automobile faut-il acheter à des
actions et quel avenir pour l'action à
tesla
ce sont les questions à qui vont nous
occuper aujourd'hui olivier alors depuis
fin 2010 9 l'action tesla un connu une
hausse en continu en janvier dernier
l'entreprise a dépassé pour la première
fois les 100 milliards de dollars de
capitalisation
tesla est ainsi passé devant volkswagen
à titre de comparaison l'allemand a
écoulé près de 11 millions de véhicules
en 2010 9 contre seulement 370 me le pot
tesla tesla est donc devenu le deuxième
constructeur mondial en valeur derrière
le japonais toyota
olivier quand on regarde le nombre de
véhicules vendus par tesla en
comparaison par exemple avec volkswagen
est ce que cette valorisation boursière
elle vous paraît excessive
c'est très excessif mais soeur en fait
ça n'a rien à voir avec la valeur de la
société
vous avez eu une simple opération de
bourse
en gros une manipulation de cours alors
la sec devrait d'ailleurs s'y
intéressaient ne le fera pas mais c'est
pas grave
en fait on a eu exactement ce qui s'est
passé sur volkswagen ya quelques années
on a créé un corner c'est à dire on a on
a empêché les jeux la sec
vous parlez de la sec la sec c'est là
c'est l'équivalent de la mf l'autorité
des marchés financiers aux états unis
est en fait un ce qui s'est passé c'est
que un certain nombre de gros
actionnaires historiques ont décidé à un
moment de d'arrêter de prêter des titres
parce qu'il faut savoir que vous pouvez
en bourse
vendre sans avoir le titre en espérant
une baisse et en espérant le racheter
plus bas et il en bourse on appelle ça
un short et donc c'est ce qui s'est
passé tout le monde savait que les
résultats de tesla était pas
extraordinaire ils ont annoncé quand
même pas loin d'un milliard de pertes
encore encore une fois pour 2019 et là
dessus donc vous avez beaucoup de gens
qui ont joué ce titre à la baisse qu'est
ce qui s'est passé le titre a atteint
ses plus bas niveaux qui étaient autour
de 200 $ et et là vous avez un certain
nombre d'actionnaires historiques qui
sont du bon ça nous fait moyen-moyen
rire cette histoire est donc on va
empêcher les gens de vendre à découvert
et pour empêcher les gens de vendre à
découvert c'est assez simple il suffit
de refuser de leur prêter les titres
vous refusez de leur prêter l'éthique
vous organisés en fait une pénurie de
titres ce qui fait que il suffit après
de donner un petit peu d'impulsions de
faire monter le titre de quelques
dizaines de dollars au départ et puis
vous affoler vous paniquez ceux qui sont
vendeurs à découvert et il se rachète et
à ce moment là vous pouvez leur revendre
jusqu'à 900 950 justement au lit dollars
ce qui est délirant mais je vous dis
c'est quelque chose qui était déjà
arrivé il ya quelques années sur le
titre volkswagen qui était passé de 100
euros à 1000 euros en quelques jours en
quelques heures
tout ça pourquoi parce qu'il y avait
plus de titres justement olivier on va
revenir sur les derniers rebondissements
de tesla le 5 février à dernier la firme
d'elon musk a abandonné jusqu'à 20% à la
bourse de new york après avoir connu nos
forêts boursière deux jours auparavant
retour sur les faits avec le tiroir cage
d'antoine la sas
mais que se passe-t-il avec tesla
début février le constructeur automobile
a connu des fluctuations de sa valeur
boursière assez inhabituel remontant le
fil de l'histoire
le 3 février dernier l'action qui était
en constante augmentation depuis fin
2010 9 fait un énorme bond en avant de
20% le 4 février un autre bond en avant
de 14%
tout ça grâce à des résultats meilleurs
que prévu au quatrième trimestre 2010 9
et des prévisions extrêmement optimiste
pour 2020 avec un objectif fixé de près
de 500 mille véhicules vendus en tout
l'action tesla a grimpé de plus de 110 %
depuis le début de l'année et de près de
400 % depuis juin dernier lui permettant
de devenir le deuxième constructeur
automobile mondial derrière toyota et
valant plus que general motors ford fiat
chrysler renault et psa réuni une bonne
nouvelle pour elon musk qui empochent
des bonus faramineux
dès que la valeur de tesla franchi
certains paliers
sauf que le lendemain le 5 février donc
patatras l'action plonge de 20%
connaissant ainsi l'une de ses plus
forte chute en passant de 887 à 724 $
la photo coronavirus qui a impacté la
production en chine
en obligeant tesla a fermé une de ses
usines se signe en tout cas d'une
certaine volatilité du titre tesla pas
du tout rassurant pour les marchés où
certains évoquent déjà le statut de
bulles ou de grenade en chocolat pour
parler de l'entreprise d'elon musk
olivier est ce qu'on peut parler de
bulle oui on peut parler de bulle c'est
à dire je vous dis c'est une
manipulation de cours pur et dur
exactement comme il y avait eu sur sur
volkswagen
aujourd'hui vous regardez le titre
volkswagen il est rentré dans le rang
s'il voulait donc là aujourd'hui on peut
pas valorisées si vous prenez la
valorisation boursière c'est à dire on
est monté jusqu'à 165 milliards pour une
boîte qui depuis le début père en cumulé
6 milliards et demi enfin je veux dire
il ya il ya un moment où il faut quand
même réfléchir à la question
il vend trois cent cinquante mille
voitures d'accord 350 mille voitures ça
veut dire que vous valoriser la voiture
à
quasiment 500 morts entre 400 et 500
mille dollars
la voiture face est ridicule pour une
voiture peut-être donc tout ça c'est
c'est de la manipulation boursière pur
et dur
après il le vend bien elon musk cc1
leveur de fonds extraordinaire c'est pas
un génie ça n'a rien à voir avec un
génie c'est un type qui aujourd'hui nous
vend du rêve et il vend très cher elle
est trop chère
classé à la deuxième partie de cette
émission on continue à d'évoquer le cas
tesla avec vincent en bois analyste
marchés chez ing france
bonjour vincent bois merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bonjour alors je vais commencer avec la
dernière question que j'ai posée à
olivier en fin de première partie
peut-on selon vous parler de bulle c'est
cela ah oui en effet on peut comparer ça
même bitcoin ou un effet au marché
actuel où les valorisations sont
extrêmement importantes par rapport aux
fondamentaux finalement que ce soit en
bourse où que ce soit également sur
tesla par rapport comme vous l'avez dit
au résultat net ou aux fondamentaux de
la société
et qu'est ce qui fait une bulle
concrètement c'est l'engouement des
acheteurs ça peut être éventuellement
une manipulation de marché mais c'est
plutôt également l'information ou les
analyses qui vont donner un flux
d'information qui va être plutôt positif
sur la société sans forcément étayer ses
dires où ces données et ensuite faire
l'effet boule de neige
je comparais cela effectivement au
bitcoin où nous avons énormément
d'investisseurs et donc au delà de la
bulle structurel avec des produits de
marché avec des positions de vente à
découvert de short comme vous l'avez dit
qu'ils sont bloqués il y a également
l'engouement de tous les investisseurs
qui va amener justement à cette bulle et
à macha excessif jusqu'à jusqu'à une
valorisation comme on l'a actuellement
qui est complètement décorrélée delà des
fondamentaux alors justement on l'a vu
en tesla est devenu le deuxième
constructeur est derrière toyota en
termes de valorisation boursière pour
autant les prévisions sont pas
astronomiques en termes de ventes ont
été celles qui prévoient en 2020 500
milles
que l'olivier parlé de manipulation vous
quel est votre avis je vois plus haut
lieu de la manipulation je parlerai plus
justement d'engouement et d'engouement
qui pourrait s'arrêter assez rapidement
sur sur cet effet de d'achat qui est
plutôt dirigée par l'analyse est ce
qu'on peut lire dans l'est dans les
marchés actuellement sur des
perspectives au delà des perspectives de
tesla qui sont effectivement un peu
légère par rapport à ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui 500 mille véhicules pour
l'année prochaine on a trois cent
soixante mille l'augmentation n'est pas
excessive en revanche en effet le fait
de donner beaucoup d'informations sans
l'étayer amène à 7 7 h en direction
ça c'est ça a toujours été le cas sur
sur tesla puis sur d'autres sur sur le
bitcoin sur sur plein de 2,2 de valeur
mais chez moi j'ai quand même
l'impression que c'est plutôt à
posteriori on cherche à justifier en
fait le l'envolée qui est pour moi une
pure envolée je dirais technique c'est à
dire je vous dis il suffit de il suffit
de bloquer le prêt emprunt de titres et
puis ça y est c'est terminé
vous n'avez plus la possibilité de
vendre à découvert le titre est à ce
moment-là vous assécher le marché
attendait donc pardon annoncé c'est de
la pure manipulation alors après que
l'on cherche à justifier par sorte de
fondamental en disant bah oui mais il va
vendre plus de voitures l'année
prochaine
ouais d'accord enfin bon mais de toute
façon jamais vous n'arriverez à
justifier en fondamental n'a jamais vous
n'arriverez à justifier un cours comme
165 milliards de capi pour un truc qui
vend 300 milles bagnols et qui perd de
l'argent
j'espère un milliard par an quand ma vie
c'est pas juste rien donc
qu'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
sur la demande c'est simplement quand
vous quand vous vendez a découvert
quelque chose il faut que vous fassiez
prêter les tic pour les vents bon donc
vous allez voir des actionnaires
historiques des gens qui en ont beaucoup
et qui voulaient prête contre
rémunération pendant un mois pendant
deux mois pendant trois mois pour que
vous puissiez les vendre à découvert
et puis les racheter plus tard
évidemment en espérant les racheter
moins cher le problème si vous voulez
c'est que finalement l'actionnaire
historique se tire un peu une balle dans
le pied c'est à dire qu'ils prêtent des
types pour qu' on puisse démonter le
type pour qu'on puisse le faire baisser
donc au bout d'un moment vous pouvez
avoir très bien les actionnaires
historiques qui disent bon ben ça y est
c'est gentil on va arrêter à nos bêtises
et puis on prêt plus de titres si vous
prêtez plus de titres les seuls qui
peuvent vendre c'est ceux qui en ont
d'accord et c'est les actionnaires il
sort qu'ils démentent pas et vous avez
et vous avez tous les gens qui sont
vendeurs à découvert parce qu'ils savent
que toute façon les résultats sont
pourris et qu'il n'arrivera jamais à
avoir des résultats qui justifie ces
coureurs-là bien il suffit que vous en
acheter quelques quelques dizaines de
milliers sur le marché vous fait monter
le titre
à ce moment là vous avez les vendeurs à
découvert qui panique qui se rachète et
là vous avez des acheteurs personne en
face aucun vendeur et donc vous créez si
vous voulez la pénurie ou créer le
corner et vous pouvez emmener un titre
et c'est exactement je vous dit ce qui
s'était passé avec volkswagen où tous
les shorts tous les gens qui étaient
vendeurs à découvert se sont retrouvés à
ne plus pouvoir acheter un titre ou
alors il devait le payer 20 30 40 pour
cent de plus et donc vous aviez eu ce
type qui avait démarré sur aucune
information si vous voulez vous étiez
passé de 100 à 1000 et vous être
descendu à 100 quelques quelques mois
plus tard une fois qu'on a fait le
le tri entre les absurdités du jour
voilà met d'accord s'angoisser l'espace
jusqu'à pas aussi vindicatif sur le fait
qu'il y ait une manipulation c'est vrai
que certaines personnes utilisent cette
montée et cet engouement pour les
investisseurs pour profiter justement
d'une hausse plus importante notamment
les investisseurs qui ont déjà des
actions qui les vendent à découvert en
effet mais la bourse reste le reflet des
profits futurs et au delà des sociétés
et aux lilas en tout cas de des voitures
en elle même il y à la technologie du
logiciel qui est à l'intérieur et il ya
également les batteries qui peuvent être
vendus ou la technologie qui peuvent
être vendus à d'autres personnes je ne
validerai pas la valorisation actuelle
qui est complètement décorrélé des
fondamentaux en effet mais après il ya
tout de même des des aspects dans cette
société qui peuvent valoir peuvent être
valorisés à une certaine d'un certain
montant son bras vous parliez
d'engouement tout à l'heure est ce que
c'est un engouement pour les pour les
véhicules électriques qui fait que
l'action ici c'est plutôt un engouement
pour l'action et pour le potentiel de
hausse à court terme aux entreprises
ce que représente l odm escaut 6 mai
mais c'est vrai on est allé beaucoup
trop loin ici il va falloir une
correction qui peut être brutal ou non
mais la valorisation actuelle est bien
bien trop importante mais au delà de ça
ce qu'on découvrira certainement dans
quelques années parce qu'avec trois cent
cinquante mille véhicules
c'est difficile à évaluer on peut on
peut évaluer la société sur d'autres
aspects que la voiture en elle-même un
messi ont marqué une courte pause rien
dans un instant bienvenue dans ces
caches si vous nous rejoignez on parle
de tesla avec vincent bois analyste
marchés chez iga france lanvin sangoy
olivier je voudrais qu'on vienne sur les
événements des 3 4 et 5 février
on l'a vu en action à tesla eu un
premier bond de 20% le trois autres bond
de 14 2 4 puis le 5 c'est la
dégringolade
le titre perd 20% on a évoqué dans le
tiroir caisse notamment le court aux
navires us pour justifier cette perte
est ce qu'il ya d'autres facteurs qui
peuvent expliquer une dégringolade de
20% en l'espace de 24 heures la prise de
bénéfices des investisseurs en effet
peut-être l'ouverture encore 2 des
ventes à découvert mais principalement
c'est l'atteinte d'objectifs par
certains certains
investisseurs ou certaines personnes qui
jouent simplement sur la spéculation et
qui vont donc vendre leurs titres pour
prendre une
une plus value de plus de 100% en
quelques semaines alors que les marchés
restent assez faiblarde en tout cas la
valorisation des marchés où l'évolution
reste assez faiblarde et certaines
personnes ont pu prendre plus de 100 %
en quelques semaines donc c'est plutôt
également d'une part la prise de
bénéfices et puis la tante de nouveaux
événements qui pourraient permettre ou
d'une nouvelle d'une nouvelle
accélération qui pourrait permettre de
racheter donc de prendre des bénéfices
un certain niveau et puis de racheter un
autre certain niveau à -20% pour
reprendre quelques pourcentages derrière
olivier à quel impact concrètement
lorsqu'un titre dégringole de la sorte
quel impact ces c'est toujours la même
chose c'est les dernières entrées qui
ont la patate chaude dans les mains est
qui et qui pleure donc mais ça vous avez
ça depuis depuis des années et des
années
c'est le principe de l'amour ça c'est
vous avez vous avez délai les les
suiveurs qui arrive après la bataille
qui comprennent pas d'ailleurs très bien
pourquoi ça a monté mais qui se disent
ça doit être génial parce que toute
façon on va pouvoir faire 40 50 % en
l'espace de deux jours ce qui est du
jamais vu et ils achètent et puis à ce
moment là ils se prennent moins 20 et en
général ça les calme pour pour un moment
mais ce qui moi me paraît intéressant
c'est que
je pense que c'est assez symptomatique
ce qui s'est passé sur tesla si vous
voulez est assez symptomatique du reste
c'est à dire que on sait aujourd'hui que
les marchés ne tiennent que par
l'intervention des banques centrales et
donc la mise à disposition de liquidités
extraordinaire et on l'a bien vu
d'ailleurs sur le corps n'a au virus
sa folle et les marchés pendant une
journée et au bout d'une journée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé la banque de
chine est intervenue les banques
centrales sont toutes avec le doigt sur
le bouton et vous avez encore une fois
quelque chose qui est totalement
décorrélé des fondamentaux vous avez les
fondamentaux d'un côté avec un marché
mondial qui ralentit avec des pays qui
sont soit en récession soit au bord de
la récession enfin en tout cas avec une
croissance qui est nul
regardez la france regardez le royaume
uni regardez le japon qui est en
récession
les boys vous êtes vous êtes aujourd'hui
avec des des fondamentaux qui sont
mauvais avec un risque alors après je me
fiche d'ailleurs de la façon dont on
compte ceux ci contre tarbes dont on
quantifie le coroner au virus est ce que
ça va avoir un impact sur le long terme
est ce que ça va pas en avoir et à la
limite on s'en fiche c'est pas le sujet
le sujet c'est que ça donne encore une
fois un prétexte aux banques centrales
pour délivrer pour faire tourner la
planche à billets pour maintenir les
taux à zéro voire négatif pour baisser
les taux d'intérêt pour relancer dès qu
eux et à ce moment là bas qu'est ce que
fait le marché il continue à monter
parce que envers et contre tout parce
que de toute façon aujourd'hui les
fondamentaux sont pas le sujet vous êtes
d'accord avec sa voix alors en effet
dans
d'un côté les banques centrales et les
trois baisses de taux de la réserve
fédérale américaine a permis de soutenir
les marchés financiers a permis de
d'atteindre des plus hauts historiques
sur les marchés le président américain
d'ailleurs ne se gêne pas pour pour le
préciser et même s'en féliciter et mais
finalement de la même façon que tesla
lorsqu'on regarde les fondamentaux
encore une fois cela est complètement
décorrélée avec un ralentissement de la
production industrielle en allemagne en
chine également même si la chine on peut
être sceptique sur la publication de
certains rapports l'allemagne les états
unis les états unis la création
d'emplois et restent bonnes mais il faut
rentrer dans le détail et 7,7
ce soutien des banques centrales est la
seule chose en effet qui continue et de
la même façon la communication positive
au travers du du de l'accord commercial
mais on n'a toujours rien vu sur cet
accord commercial donc cela reste assez
assez sur le papier en effet tout va
bien mais finalement si on regarde dans
le détail grâce aux banques centrales
qui leur discours d'un côté précise que
l'économie va bien mais tout de même on
a besoin de la soutenir et de façon
importante au travers des taux au
travers d'injections de liquidités pour
pas qu'il y ait de crash donc en effet
on est entendu sonic dans une économie
qui peut et les cours le le le montre
qui peut ressembler à celle de tesla où
il n'ya aucun rapport avec cette
valorisation des marchés est et ce qu'on
voit sur le vous avez vous avez une
déconnexion complète entre la valeur et
le prix mais c'est à dire que la valeur
elle elle reste ce qu'elle est et
aujourd'hui plus personne s'en occupe
et puis vous avez le prix le prix en
fait on est dans un régime de prix
administrés
on n'est plus dans un régime de prix de
marché le prix de marché il est fait par
les banques centrales en fait et donc
vous devez vous êtes dans un régime de
prix administrés qui fait que c'est
totalement déconnecté donc il faut pas
chercher de rapport entre la valeur la
valeur intrinsèque des choses et le prix
parce que le prix il est il est fixé en
fait et donc chercher alors après on
peut toujours a posteriori essayer de
donner des fondamentaux pour essayer de
coller à cette hausse ou
en disant oui mais on va peut-être qu'on
va repartir peut-être oui d'accord
enfin là aujourd'hui rien ne justifie ni
les prix qu'on a sur les marchés ni le
prix qu'on a sur tesla ni hier le prêt
quand on avait sur volkswagen la réalité
c'est ça c'est des forêts ce sont des
policiers grecs
volkswagen est ce qu il yad autres
entreprises qui ont des parcours
boursiers un peu similaire il en a de
nombreuses sociétés même si on regarde
google ou les gaffes à les gaffes a donc
c'est plutôt facebook amazon google qui
ont une progression extrêmement
importante même si les projections donc
encore une fois sont les projections et
les perspectives d'avenir sont plutôt
intéressantes mais on peut regarder sur
le corona virus on peut regarder par
exemple les sociétés qui font des
masques ou les sociétés qui qui
communique sur le fait de pouvoir
trouver éventuellement un vaccin un
vaccin c'est plutôt quinze à vingt ans
de recherches et le fait de produire des
masques même si la capacité de
production est pas suffisante pour
atteindre ses objectifs
vous pouvez regarder je n'ai pas de
d'exemple mais novavax c'est une société
qui donnait plutôt dans les mé lé les
remèdes
mais le temps de trouver un remède a
priori on l'espère ce sera déjà résolu
donc de la même façon c'est une
communication qui est plutôt positive
sur finalement défaits ou des choses
qu'on ne peut pas vérifier qu'ils sont
difficilement rejoignent à bhl ou en
tout cas qui vont être difficiles à
trouver donc jugé peu d'exemples à vous
donner au delà des dégâts femme qui est
un peu plus pertinents mais sur le
corona virus je vous invite à regarder
les masques ou des personnes qui ont qui
ont prédit qu'ils allaient trouver un
remède mais sans dire quand et comment
et quel avenir pour ce genre d'actions
quel avenir en boursiers pour un
l'action tesla l'avenir peut être
intéressant mais il va falloir une
grosse correction comme sur les marchés
globaux
on voit généralement une crise peut-être
tous les dix ans qui permet justement de
retrouver la santé au marché qui permet
de rééquilibrer un peu la valorisation
et les fondamentaux chez tesla il va lui
falloir une correction comme je le
disais tout à l'heure mais qu'elle soit
rapide ou non mais il va falloir
corriger pour re rentrer dedans et
d'autre part pour essayer de repartir à
la hausse
il va falloir prouver que l'action texas
ou que la technologie qui est dans cette
société peut conduire la valorisation de
l'action à un des niveaux à des pics
extrêmement élevé merci a beaucoup
avancé pour sa part été parmi nous sur
ce plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste marchés chez ing france on
passe à l'actualité de la semaine
olivier les retraits d'argent liquide
vont-ils nous coûter plus cher
la question se pose car au 1er janvier
2020 la commission interbancaire de
retrait a augmenté de 56% de 57 centimes
elle est passée à 89 centimes olivier
est ce que cette hausse pourrait se
répercuter chez les consommateurs à bâle
va se répercuter chez les consommateurs
mais c'est le on est dans le le
processus qui consiste à supprimer le
cash on a fait une émission là dessus il
ya quelques quelques mois c'est une
mesure anti cash petit à petit vont
supprimer parce que le le but du jeu
c'est de contrôler vos vif à part si
vous n'avez pas encore compris ça le
gouvernement les autorités veulent
absolument tout savoir de vous et tout
contrôler et donc une fois que vous le
cache aura disparu or sous des prétextes
qui peuvent être les coûts induits pour
les banques qui peuvent être le
terrorisme le blanchiment et c'est bien
sûr parce qu'il faut quand même des
millions et des millions de dollars pour
prendre une camionnette et foncé dans la
foule ça c'est sûr que c'est
c'est pour enrayer blanchiment le c'est
non non c'est pas pour enrayer
blanchiment ça c'est le prétexte le
blanchiment c'est ça pour enrayer le
blanchiment c'est simplement pour
contrôler movie est donc une fois que
vous aurez tout à disposition des
banques parce que vous paierez avec
votre téléphone
parce que vous ne pourrez plus payer que
par téléphone votre carte bleue et que
vous n'aurez absolument plus de cash
vous n'aurez absolument plus aucun
secret c'est à dire que on saura ce que
vous mangez ce que vous fumez ce que
vous buvez ce que comment vous passez
vos vacances si vous faites du sport si
vous en faites pas etc
et croyez moi à ses fichiers là seront
revendus à qui de droit et vous aurez
votre assureur qui vous dira ah ben non
moi je vous assure pas monsieur parce
que vous mangez trop gras ou vous fumez
ou etc
ou alors je vous mets une prime
démentiel c'est ça qui nous attend sauf
que les gens sont ravis parce que c'est
vrai que ces pratiques de payer sans
contact avec sa carte bleue et que c'est
facile et que tout le monde est content
sauf qu'il y a il ya des conséquences et
l'avenir nous le dira je vous rappelle
qu'à ce sujet vous pouvez retrouvez
notre émission sur la possible
disparition de l'arc de l'argent liquide
sur rt france point tv on passe au des
briques des commentaires et avant de
refermer cette émission comme à chaque
fois olivier delamarche débrief vos
commentaires la semaine dernière
l'émission était consacrée au pétrole et
plus particulièrement au pétrole de
schiste américains voici et les
commentaires sélectionnés et celui de
flash non ce n'est pas parce que le
pétrole est consommable qu'il était
puise à bhl mais parce que c'est un
stock comme le charbon ou l'uranium à la
différence de la lumière du soleil du
vent de la houle du courant des rivières
qui sont des flux c'est bien flash par
le français on n'a pas dit le contraire
donc oui c'est un stock comme
comme le peut l'être le gaz naturel
comme peut l'être beaucoup de deux
d'énergie aujourd'hui comme l'est le
charbon comme l'est aussi
l'uranium etc oui ce sont des stocks ccc
bien voilà commentaires suivants
thebluepill fin du pétrole égale fin du
game égale effondrement le pétrole c'est
90 % de l'énergie consommée dans le
monde nous sommes possiblement en pic
pétrolier depuis 2018 après le pic la
chute la décroissance forcé est
inévitable et proche c'est-à-dire failli
de l'euro du dollar des dettes d'état de
la finance de la bourse pouvoir d'achat
état providence un garçon optimiste je
bouquine un mais
oui écoutez je sais pas si c'est si
c'est dans dix ans dans moins de dix ans
dans plus de 10 ans dans 15 ans et c'est
toute façon ce genre de prévisions vous
savez s'avère fausse ça fait 15 ans
qu'on nous dit qu'il ya ou vingt ans
qu'on nous dit qu'il ya plus de pétrole
ça fait il ya 20 ans ont utilisé que les
chinois seraient les maîtres du monde et
c'est enfin tout ça c'est c'est des
prévisions qui malheureusement fin ou
heureusement en tout cas ne se ne
s'avère pas vrai
ce qui est vrai c'est que on sait que
toute façon c'est en effet un stock a
donc premier commentaire bon un stock
c'est un stock et que comme tous les
stocks
il a une fin donc évidemment ça va poser
des problèmes d'autant plus qu' on n'a
quand même pas l'impression que nos
grands manitous
réfléchissent à l'après pétrole on a
l'impression plutôt que c'est le la
gabegie et qu' on en profite parce que
toute façon c'est une énergie qui n'est
pas très cher merci olivier c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro en attendant pourvoir
au revoir nos précédentes émissions
rendez vous sur rt france point tv
n'hésitez pas non plus à réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag rt cash
olivier le mot de la fin
rendez vous pour la 50e